[Music]
this morning in our Saturday session
singer-songwriter Emily King the New
York native and Grammy nominee has long
won acclaim for her intricate blend of
R&B and soul but the release of her
third album this month has earned her
special praise and not just from critics
and fans but from some of the biggest
names in music including John Legend Sam
Smith Sara Bareilles and Justin
Timberlake will hear selections from her
new album in just a moment but first I
had a chance to talk with Emily King at
the Mexico rehearsal studio here in New
York Emily King has music in her blood
her parents
Marian cowlings and Kim Coletti are both
jazz singers and she grew up in New York
watching them perform how soon did you
know you wanted to do the same I think
it was always just put in my spirit I
don't think I was very good as a child I
was not a prodigy or anything mm-hmm
I think I just kind of forced the issue
at 15 she started writing songs I
discovered the beatles around that age
and you know that's when i was like okay
songs even more than albums i love songs
can i be the person that writes a song
let me try it my mom helped me get a gig
at the bitter end that was my first gig
ever she's like if you write 10 songs I
know the guy Dan he works there all my
neighbors came yeah and how'd you do
terrible that's cuz you stack the
audience in 2004 at age 19 she was
signed to Clive Davis's Jay records what
were you thinking at that moment
I'm famous now later I gotta go I was
late for my award show
her debut album East Side Story released
in 2007 was nominated for a Grammy but a
year later she split with her label what
did you take away from that you can't
fool yourself
I've tried and it just doesn't work so I
think that's what I took from that
situation is like just go with your
instinct specially creatively King has
evolved into an acclaimed songwriter
winning the Songwriters Hall of Fame's
Holly Prize in 2012 which honors
exceptionally talented and inspired
young musicians how do you come up with
songs I still don't know okay I mean
it's kind of there is a magic to it
isn't magic to it I think a part of it
is just being open yeah to whatever is
going to come to you and and showing up
for the job and sing
[Music]
for Emily Kings it usually starts with a
melody sometimes the words will come out
as a mumble I can't hold me as a song on
my record that I had mumbled these you
can hold me now or something I mean I'm
I'm out like that I thought that sounds
good but maybe I should try something
else